I love telling myself that size doesn't
matter but today that is all that we're
going to talk about because we're going
from the tiniest creatures in one piece
to behemoths that are so big that Mount
Everest wouldn't even reach their knees
but first here is the smallest character
ever in one piece this is Monterey the
princess of the tontada a small tribe of
tiny dwarves the size of a chopstick
that are actually so small and so fast
that the citizens of dressrosa rarely
ever get to see them and monshuri is the
smallest even among these dwarfs at only
20 centimeters or about 8 inches tall
which is barely even the height of a
regular dinnerfork but moving from the
smallest creature to the smallest Straw
Hat we have Tony Tony Chopper now
obviously Chopper can vary in size
because his own type devil fruit allows
Chopper to change forms and to be fair
to Chopper in his monster Point form he
is several meters tall but for our
purposes we're talking about Chopper in
his base form which is this adorable
baseball bat-sized doctor which measures
90 centimeters or just under three feet
he's a pretty tiny guy and we love it
that way now compared to that Monkey D
Luffy our main protagonist is a true
giant who comes in at one meter 74 when
he's not stretched out that is that's
about five foot seven which
coincidentally is the average height of
the average man worldwide which seems
too specific to be a coincidence but
looking at Luffy staring down like
literally any of the antagonists of the
series we can tell that things are about
to get crazy when it comes to how tall
some characters truly are and we're not
even talking about things like sea Kings
or the gates of Justice yes first though
which is still realistic in our actual
world is Shanks now this yonko stands
two meters tall or about six foot five
and while this is pretty damn tall there
are people who are this tall for frame
of reference two meters is about the
height of an average door which also
does mean that from here on out every
character that we discuss is going to
have to lean down really far whenever
they walk into a room or in some cases
they just have no hope at all of ever
fitting through a door at all which kind
of makes me wonder are buildings in the
one piece world just bigger than in real
life or what's the deal here like what
about people like I don't know jimbei
who's a whooping three meters tall for
the mathematically impaired that's one
and a half Shanks is or 10 feet tall and
this makes sense given that in general a
lot of the fishermen tend to be bigger
and stronger than the average human but
on top of that jimbei is also a whale
shark fisherman now in case you don't
know whale sharks just so happen to be
the biggest species of fish in the world
well our world anyways so it's really no
surprise that he Towers about many of
his crewmates but it's of course nothing
compared to some of the absolutely
massive sea creatures still coming up
for now though we're sticking to people
as we go to another one of the yonko
Luffy's biggest rival Blackbeard now
Marshall the teach is 3 meters and 44
centimeters tall which is over 11 feet
I don't know I somehow never imagined
that blackbeat was that much taller than
jimbei I mean before now I've always
kind of wondered how he was ever able to
give Shanks out of all people his
signature scars and height isn't
everything but he's almost twice as tall
as Shanks but as you know he is far from
the biggest member of his crew and he's
also nowhere near the size of the
warlord Bartholomew Kuma now whenever we
do see Kuma he's straight out Towers
over regular people like Luffy and Co
from his first meeting with the straw
hats on Thriller bark to him destroying
the entire crew on Saba ODI archipelago
this fearsome formal warlord is 6.89
meters tall two times the height of the
already massive Blackbeard which is 22
feet this man is huge I mean we've heard
hints in the story that Kuma comes from
a special race of people but it's still
kind of hard to grasp how a person who
is not a giant can be as as tall as two
elephants stacked on top of each other
kaido in his base form though is even
taller at 7.10 meters and for some
reference that's about the average
height of a traffic light now it is no
wonder that for the fight with Luffy
onigashima he had to take things to the
rooftop I mean sure he did use the
excuse of not being able to fit in this
crazy huge Dragon for him but it's 23
feet tall it's amazing that he has any
clearance in his hallways whatsoever
thankfully oneigashima is big enough to
fit the actual number so it's probably
the only building in wano that has
enough space for him to stretch his legs
and it really makes you wonder just how
big onigashima is little tease there now
big mom stays true to her name of course
because she is 8.8 meters tall which is
almost 29 feet and she's about the
height of a three-story building so it
is no wonder that both her children and
her husbands are terrified of her she
really does take the whole cake being
the biggest of all the yonko and it's no
wonder that she's sour about Lola's
engagement to Loki the prince of the
Giants falling through as well after all
if she had a few more Giants around she
might finally be able to realize her
dream of having everyone sitting around
a table at her own level and then there
is Shira Hoshi the mermaid princess of
Fishman Island who is just absurdly big
she's
11.87 meters or 39 feet tall and it's
wild that she's so cowardly given that
she could look at Brachiosaurus in the
eye no problem it's really amazing that
vendor deck and this guy here was able
to torment her so much considering that
she could prob probably pick him up and
eats him all the way to the surface if
she really wanted to and honestly
looking at her parents King Neptune and
queen oruhime I mean first of all how
did this work and also I don't
understand how she could be this big of
course though she is nothing compared to
the Fearsome sea Kings she commands as
you can see in this panel here but more
on those a little bit later from here on
out every single entry is officially
giant sized hydrogen a member of the
giant pirates for example and now one of
Luffy's subordinates in the grand Fleet
is 22 meters tall that is 72 feet or
about the height of two telephone poles
stacked on top of each other it really
just makes it much more impressive how
easily Luffy was able to take hydrogen
out at the dresserosa Coliseum and even
more impressive that Luffy has a
vertical leap that is 13 times his own
height next up the Thousand Sunny the
straw Hat's official ship is 56 meters
or 183 feet at its tall this point and
it does make sense that boats in the one
piece world have to be enormous given
how massive the characters we've already
talked about actually are and even being
as big as it is compared to their
original ship the going Mary the sunny
is absolutely dwarfed by other ships
like big mom's Flagship and now we have
oryx the ancient giant who was 67 meters
or 219 feet tall this character was
resurrected as a zombie by gekkomoria's
Shadow ability and it's no wonder that
Moria wanted this diseased Warrior to be
the centerpiece of his Undead Army I
mean laying down orus would measure the
same length as a 747's entire wingspan
and if that's somehow hard to imagine
let's just say that jumbo jets are
called jumbo jets for a very good reason
however even this gigantuous ancient
warrior can't measure up to wadatsumi
the Giant Tiger Blowfish fish man
because he is 80 meters or 262 feet tall
which made him a terrifying Ally of the
new fisherman Pirates and it's actually
really well to think that he's based on
a blowfish too because that means that
he can puff himself up to become even
bigger he is by far the biggest Fishman
but he is still nothing compared to the
biggest giant ever San Juan wolf one of
the Blackbeard's 10 Titanic captains San
Juan wolf is the only giant who is
confirmed to have eaten a devil fruit
and this devil fruit the enlargement
devil fruit that we just learned about
made him absolutely massive wolf is 183
meters tall that is 600 feet and since
these numbers are just starting to get
really hard to imagine at this point
that's the height of the Space Needle
which is this here San Juan wolf is so
huge that even though he's a devil fruit
user he can freely enter the ocean he
won't drown because he is tall enough
that his feet reach the bottom and he
can just stand in the sea without having
to worry about not being able to swim
which I guess is a way to uh go around
the entire drowning in the sea downside
of devil fruits but now we go from the
sea all the way up to the sky with one
of one piece's longest creatures ever
Nola the snake who's lived in shandora
for 400 years and in all that time Nola
Grew From This cute little reptile that
we see in Nolan and khalgara's flashback
to this easily able to swallow Luffy
whole this serpent is 200 meters or 656
feet long making him one of the oldest
and biggest animals in all of One Piece
however Nola isn't as big as surume a
300 meter tall Kraken who Luffy
befriended on his way to Fishman Islands
now 300 meter translates to 984 feet or
just chai of the Eiffel Tower and as the
crew descended beneath the red line
towards Fishman Islands they didn't
expect to encounter a sea creature that
ridiculously big thankfully enough
though Luffy makes friends everywhere he
goes and soon the crew had a new many
armed gigantuous Ally but from the
entrance to the new world now we go back
to the entrance of the grand line
altogether with Le Boon you might
remember that the giant whale that
swallowed the crew as soon as they
entered the grand line through reverse
Mountain measures 400 meters or
1312 feet from head to tail and given
how much he grew ever since he was a
baby who knows if Brooke would even
recognize this Behemoth if he got to
meet him again and apparently at the
beginning of the grand line Oda was just
really on a kick of introducing absolute
huge monsters because now we go from
Lagoon to this fish here which is a
massive island-sized goldfish that
almost swallowed the entire island of
little garden this 750 meter or 2 345
feet Beast is almost as long as the Burj
Khalifa is tall you know the tallest
building in the entire world local
Dorian bragi had some giant size
strength to be able to quite easily
actually defeat it and save the day but
now we move from giant creatures to the
biggest ship in the series The Noah and
now we're at a scale so big that meters
and feet just really aren't cutting it
anymore at 2 500 meters it's just a lot
easier to just say 2.5 kilometers and we
also have our first entry over a mile at
8202 feet Alton Casey wondering one mile
is exactly 5280 feet wait is that how
the imperial system works why would it
be
5200 anyway the NOAA is a massive Arc
built with the intention of someday
bringing the entire population of
Fishman Island millions of people to the
surface unfortunately Luffy destroyed it
now hopefully it gets rebuilt before he
also destroys fisherman Island one day
but even this gigantuous boat doesn't
stack up to the biggest door in all of
anime I will say which are the gates of
justice and we don't have any official
numbers for them but doing some real
life calculations we can estimate them
to be about three kilometers or nearly
two miles high including the underwater
portions that is the world government
has done some really impressive things
to be able to control an entire planet
but among the most impressive is easily
this remarkable feat of engineering here
but now we go from a man-made structure
to one that is seemingly all natural the
giant skull that the giant creature
kaido lives in easily on onegashima this
thing is 3.7 kilometers high and over
two miles it's so massive it really
makes you wonder how big this ancient
giant creature was when it was alive
like this is only the heads which is why
we're gonna calculate it you see if you
take the hypotenuse and multiply by the
square root of the quotient of the
factor in the permutations of the Prime
Meridian okay you know I'm just
bullshitting of course actually it was a
lot easier than that if we assume an
ancient giant had similar proportions to
a human its total height should be about
eight times the size of its head and so
we can assume that his full height went
alive was 29
320 meters or approximately 18 miles
tall absurdly large but still not the
biggest thing that we'll get on this
list but first some huge things that are
just a little bit smaller than that you
see it just feels wrong to describe the
sea Kings as small in any way even when
speaking in relative turns but at an
average length of 5 kilometers or about
three miles it is no wonder that
Poseidon's power to control these
leviathans is considered an ancient
weapon just to paint a picture they are
longer than the city of of Manhattan is
white from River to River and twice as
big as that though is the red line at 10
kilometers or about six miles high in
other words the red line is taller than
Mount Everest which is even more
impressive when you consider that the
red line is like a Mount Everest that
stretches around the entire
circumference of the one-piece planets I
can really see how having that in real
life would put a damper on any
international travel plans and it also
makes it even more impressive that
fisher tiger actually climbed this thing
with his bare feet all the way but now
we are actually getting to the
officially biggest things in the series
starting off with zunisha including his
legs that can easily reach the sea floor
so that he can walk around the ocean is
35 kilometers tall that's about
21.7 miles or in other words the size of
four mine don't everests and that just
really makes you feel worse for this
little pink dragon and had to carry the
straw heads all the way up to the top
rest in peace my friends and this next
one is a little bit more of an estimate
but these Shadows of the shandyan
Warriors casting down from the sky
though just the shadows of normal sized
people measure about 44 kilometers or 27
miles high and a lot of people confuse
those Shadows with these here those are
not the same things these are the
Florian triangle monsters and these
mysterious and still unexplained
creatures are based on Japanese Yokai
called Umi bosu enormous sea monster
said to destroy entire ships and if you
look at this panel you can see Thriller
bark which is an entire island-sized
ship at its feet at our best estimate we
can guess that these entities are 54
kilometers or 33 miles high making them
the biggest and maybe most mysterious
thing in all of One Piece and in
addition to this mystery there are tons
of other unexplained things in one piece
and you can shake all of them out in
this video where we go over every single
unsolved mystery that still needs
answers before the end of the series
thanks for watching